yeah hello and welcome to this video
Hyper's always the appellant i'm not
actually able to yeah to close this
bottle that's a bad sign so m banco
accepted banco okay can still play d 60
on yes he does okay okay i should really
refresh this a little bit i will keep
getting into trouble with this line ok
so here i can maybe i can start with
this actually I like this night to e8 at
the end to go to be five a deal I could
do it right away please let's good as a
five is immediately hanging if he takes
me maybe unite a force is again the who
has happened to me in earlier games no
but that looks excellent I just have an
initiative on the green side for form
for nothing I think happy to play this
oh yeah I think night takes because I'm
ready to play night before d3
potentially maybe not you know now you
can do this Queenie truth
[Music]
okay still have to do this I guess it is
perfectly fine I mean I'm looking at the
d5 pawn maybe we should defy him maybe
he intends to unpin I have an idea why
not put this here so that potential F
success is possible simply to stop the
pawns and keep my bishop actors okay
he's anticipating this idea okay ready
for trade
I'm actually threatening almost almost
Bishop takes between very close but this
should be true Queen takes as possible
so night a to what's happening Queen g4
yeah 24 he needs this he needs to smooth
otherwise but it might work it's a
checkmate idea f5 takes it I takes you
want but and some I'm probably getting
mated I did not really assess this
correctly with the with each six light a
true Queen g4 is really an issue but
maybe I'm not mated famous last words I
guess ok show me you can check waited
nothing I can do ok I was really
thinking Queen g4s critical but can't
seem to be the case so now
fania by 24 f five ticks with Quincy for
takes on g6 I don't think i'm getting
mated my bishop here should defend it
might be a draw but ok that's what it is
iff Bishop takes extra this is extremely
lucky I did not see that so we cannot
take here because of the sugar f too wet
I'm lucky here I thought he can take and
probably have enough for some a
perpetual but I'm threatening be sugar
to that probably winds from him he
doesn't really have a useful move and I
have Queenie truth if you place I'm not
sure what exactly Eric we need to answer
is going to win or queen bee three time
18 23 is better or at least easier a
queen trade will be enough play he has
that was weird technically very very
sharp yes so the opening was a sorry yay
what was nice to me I'm definitely in
good shape so yeah maybe maybe at the
end of the day this a stronger and then
do it like that I was somehow fascinated
by and by the night before thing that he
gets a good setup here I thought okay
it's a
payment I cannot do much about it and
this is dangerous I probably should
react to it somehow create for King f-86
computer move now King f8 so if i do
this and he plays the smooth 93 because
it isn't actually a checkmate king of a
this is the idea so that Quincy fourth
lot of sweat interesting okay i played
this and Bishop e2 so that ultimately
did not work yeah i was thinking here
here and what I saw with molly was that
I will take here and I thought this is a
draw which is no we can actually win Wow
so here here and m6 oh my god has been
knighted all of a sudden check check
check yeah and he wins everything at the
end eh phone does it that's great I mean
it does work for me but I did not see it
perform this is winning because of this
thread the same ideas in the game yeah
so here and he has to go Quincy to hail
Queen actually have one looks very star
giveth and the sisters and work because
of that intermediate check we are
Queenie to also but this little
Servilius because I'm enforcing the
Queen trade basically
quick tough game thanks for watching I
forgot to switch on the engine again now
anyway thanks for watching